my first guest he's someone who always
hold a very special place in my heart
because he was the first person to
interview me on TV after I won American
Idol and he's also my favorite host of
all time
take a look I mean did you did you think
you would win were you that confident
you couldn't be modest but you Dante did
you cuz I'm not true when you enter when
you enter these contests do you have in
the back your mind I can win this you
just try to go week to week I mean I'm
very day by day I don't like to think
too far ahead or I'll start to stress
myself out but um you know nobody coming
into this thought this show for when I
don't think it's gonna be that huge yeah
and then nobody felt you know you're
gonna be the winner one out of 10,000
yeah that's part of the odds it's pretty
good all right look look
[Applause]
[Music]
I've always thought about like up you
said the odds are winning a 1 in 10,000
what are the odds and I said well the
odds are 1 in myself wait do you hate
watching interviews of yourself and your
younger I don't even do it I don't
really want instead of like no sis's
staring at my own reflection oh yeah
once a while something comes up I want
to see you know an old star somehow God
look at them I'm not really oh well
that's gonna cost them but that's right
17 years ago just the fact you said on
TV I'm your first I thought that was
yeah all right we actually dug up
because I love you so much I do I'm a
weird stalker love but anyway I found a
picture from like the first day since
this is like the first season for me
okay I found a picture of you hosting
pokers time here we go
[Applause]
yes yes so handsome that's right anybody
tuning in right now go whoa I didn't
know that that's how she got on the show
well when you're good you're good
no no I just I loved going in a show I
thought you were just so much fun and so
kind and you were just my favorite host
I know I say that it sounds cliche
because I'm gonna show but you're always
so kind and you came to everybody's
dressing room you that's my favorite
thing about you and you like really
invested in people and it mattered and
you cared and I thought that was really
I was like this you gave me a you give
me a bottle of wine thank you I love
wine I did what my mom liked I'm not a
big wine my mom in fact my actually this
kind of ties in with daytime talk shows
because my mom had a ritual she would
watch her story and then she would watch
The Oprah okay not Oprah and and the
older my mother God the more wine you
know so one day I go on the den and she
Scott I see the bottles only got about
this much left and she's got and she's
got this glassy look I my mother was
from Scotland she goes Jamie Jamie I got
a question what is it mom
I'm watching the opener she says and the
lesbian people I don't understand what
it is they do when they get together you
know mom is all out of my wheelhouse
want to get daddy in here nothing a
lesbian I really can't answer this
question you know it was uncomfortable
she's got the wine I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this